[Musica]
[Applauso]
lista parziale
delle cose di cui un po ci importa chi
va a letto con chi come fare soldi nel
tal modo
illustrare la vetrina dalla quale ci
mostriamo
sembrare belli giovani e intelligenti
facendolo apparire meno gli altri avere
un'opinione su tutto avere ragione
essere efficienti efficaci e performanti
ed ora una lista sempre parziale delle
cose di cui a mio sommesso avviso invece
non ci importa abbastanza
in ordine sparso la crisi climatica
lamal distribuzione delle risorse sulla
terra
il rischio della tuttologia
l'analfabetismo funzionale la parità di
genere la salute mentale nella
popolazione generale il maltrattamento e
l'abuso minorili
e infine una lista questa volta completa
delle cose in cui invece non ci importa
per nulla la questione dei giovani
adulti
ignorati dalla politica
ridicolizzati dal mercato del lavoro
esclusi dal carrello dei consumi
ostaggio della famiglia mal
rappresentati dai mezzi di comunicazione
la verità è che dei ragazzi
o non si parla o quando si parla di loro
li si racconta male
la yomo jose ca a 23 anni a seguito
della vittoria al primo turno agli open
di francia del 2021 non si è presentata
in conferenza stampa aveva
preventivamente avvisato gli
organizzatori del torneo che si sentisse
particolarmente ansiosa e quindi che
preferisse per la sua salute il suo
equilibrio psichico e per mantenere la
concentrazione
non incontrare i giornalisti prima della
fine della competizione
ha seguito però delle pressioni degli
organizzatori che dicevano che avrebbe
subito delle conseguenze per via del suo
comportamento e dopo essere stata
multata per 15mila dollari rinuncia al
roland garros lo fa per se stessa le
viene riconosciuto il tentativo di
stigmatizzazione del disagio psichico al
times dir anche di averlo fatto per
porre l'attenzione sul sistema di
punizioni a suo dire eccessivamente
formale e obsoleto a cui sono sottoposti
i tennisti
puniti a fronte di una presenza in campo
ma di una mancata presenza in conferenza
stampa
non verrà ben ascoltata di conseguenza
non verrà capita e per quanto nyomm iosa
che vedete sia un attivista per i
diritti delle minoranze
la tennista numero tre al mondo
la prima asiatica di tutti i tempi a
raggiungere il primo posto nel ranking
mondiale e dal 2019 l'atleta donna più
pagata di tutti i tempi in realtà è
stata gettata in pasto ai commenti sia
social ma anche istituzionali di chi
invece l'ha definita
capricciosa
indegna del posto che occupa nella
classifica mondo se non sa reggere la
pressione
una tennista che non sa fare il suo
dovere e
troppo ricca per avere ancora voglia di
mettersi in gioco
il suo nome tra i tanti tra cui avrei
potuto attingere io sapevo da tempo di
questo appuntamento di oggi sapevo anche
con precisione che cosa avessi l'urgenza
di dire ma mi accorgevo che il suo era
un nome che mi picchiava in testa perché
questa storia la trovavo particolarmente
esemplificativa del fenomeno su cui sto
studiando e acquisto assistendo cioè per
l'appunto che se si parla e sottolineo
se dei giovani adulti al massimo lo si
fa per calare loro dall'alto il merito
di aver sdoganato
con la fragilità ma non senza mancare di
intendere tra le righe che in fondo la
fragilità va bene però dai è roba per
chi non ce l'ha fatta
c'è la fragilità e per chi alla fine ha
fallito perché non ha performato perché
non sia omologato a una certa idea dello
stare al mondo di chi è più vecchio di
loro
ea me questo
oltre che ingiusto sembra proprio falso
vedete io da quasi 20 anni faccio la
psicoterapeuta dell'adolescenza però
nell'ultimo periodo mi sono ritrovata
senza lavoro da che abbiamo fatto
estinguere gli adolescenti
nella stanza delle parole di noi
psicologi non si sono visti più
però sapendo io fare poco altro nella
vita oltre che ascoltare le storie
raccontate dai protagonisti sono rimasta
seduta sulla poltrona del mio studio per
vedere chi sarebbe arrivato dopo di loro
e il divano si è riempito di giovani
adulti
vengono in terapia perché sono alla
deriva
salpati trionfalmente come il titanic
sono poi andati incontro a ben più di un
rischio di naufragio
non sanno chi sono non sanno cosa gli
piaccia non sanno cosa vogliano non
sanno cosa sia lecito e cosa no non
sanno se lasciare il fidanzato la
fidanzata non sanno cosa possano dire
alla mamma
non sanno più studiare
e se lavorano non sono felici
vengono raccontati come adolescenti
tardivi che stanno pagando con le more
gli interessi il fatto di aver saltato a
piè pari la rivoluzione che non hanno
fatto negli anni della scuola superiore
incerti insicuri immaturi mammoni
dipendenti inconsistenti incapaci
fragili fragili soprattutto è voi aprite
un magazine a caso o un social network
qualunque e oggi ci troverete di sicuro
alla voce di chi non la loro è perché la
loro resta muta o e al massimo un rumore
di fondo
la voce di chi vi dicevo li racconta
come senti qua gli araldi della
vulnerabilità
traduco gli scopritori dell'acqua calda
e nessuno è mai passato alla storia per
aver scoperto l'acqua calda dai lo
sappiamo no ora il punto è perché sta
succedendo questo è la mia ipotesi è
propaganda
o io lo capisco e ci ha visti da qua
dalla riva mentre li vedi annaspare
mentre rischiano continuamente di
annegare a fronte dei loro tentativi
sembrano in effetti in attrezzati
inconsistenti poco credibili
però anche le anatre sempre se le guardi
da qua dalla riva sembra che veleggiano
senza fare nessuna fatica sull'acqua è
invece sotto anno le zampette che stanno
vorticando forsennatamente
io credo che solo per chi è letterale le
cose sono come sembrano
per tutti gli altri
se vai a guardare da vicino se non ti
accontenti
se vai a cercare una restituzione di
senso trovi un'altra verità ea me
l'hanno spiegata loro
ambra 25 anni quando ne aveva 15 alla
fidanzata in casa con quello che credeva
sarebbe stato l'uomo della sua vita il
futuro padre dei suoi figli che l'ha
lasciata per mettersi con una ragazza
bionda
è stato allora che ci siamo conosciute
per la prima volta era arrivata in
studio per mettere le bende al suo
giovane cuore ferito poi ha fatto un
altro passaggio veloce qualche anno dopo
ad hoc cosa scelgo dopo la laurea
triennale come mi oriento e poi e solo
ultimamente che si è
ristabilita sul divano della nostra
stanza delle parole non sa neanche lei
bene bene perché venga e tutto il primo
periodo è venuta colloquio portando con
sé il diario di nina lugo sky a che
apriva su una pagina a caso e che
leggeva prendendo a prestito le parole
parlava ambra e non si capiva di chi nel
frattempo lo studio aveva subito una
battuta d'arresto viveva ancora in casa
dove oltre che lei e suoi genitori
c'erano le tre sorelle maggiori non
sapeva più bene di che cosa parlare con
le sue amiche storiche faceva incontri
random sapete no con quelle app di
dating online puntualmente si innamorava
e tutte le volte ci restava male in più
ciliegina sulla torta è come se non
fosse bastato ottimo alibi per non
consegnare una tesi che la sua relatrice
aspettava da tempo si era messa a
lavorare facendo tutt'altro rispetto a
quello che era il suo corso di studi
e se tu le chiede vi o meglio e gliel'ho
chiesto ma perché
lei onestamente ti rispondeva
non so
mi ha molto preoccupata
ambra l'estate scorsa dopo aver tolto di
mezzo la lugo sky ha tolto di mezzo il
rossetto che si metteva pervenire in
seduta tentando di darsi un tono
tolta la sua famiglia laura di famiglia
perfetta che lei le aveva conferito e
una volta che aveva litigato
definitivamente con la sua migliore
amica di lei era rimasto molto poco e
aveva toccato il fondo
confidavo nelle sue risorse tante di
qualità però vedete quando nemmeno tu ci
sei più per te
rischia di essere davvero nei guai
vorrei raccontarvi di più di lei la sua
una storia che merita biografia ma non è
questo il punto il punta che ve ne parlo
perché una sera ambra mi dice
sto sgomitando per essere felice in un
mondo apparecchiato per l'infelicità
mondo apparecchiato per l'infelicità ed
ecco svelato il trucco del mago lì ho
capito
questi giovani adulti che sarebbe ora di
cominciare a chiamare adulti giovani non
stanno affatto sdoganando la fragilità
non stanno rivendicando di poter fallire
non stanno facendo niente del genere
stanno al contrario al contrario
rimettendo al centro
un'idea di qualità come unico criterio
possibile per una vita di salute
sia più vecchio di loro non lo capisce o
finge di non capirlo ma d'altronde a chi
è più vecchio di loro sono successe due
cose o ce l'ha già fatto non ce l'ha
ancora fatta
se ce l'ha già fatta non vede perché non
dovrebbe farcela chiunque altro
se non ce l'hanno ancora fatta o non
vedono perché non dovrebbero farcela
proprio per riscattarli i loro figli al
posto loro
o perché dovrebbero farcela proprio loro
figli se non ce l'hanno fatta neanche
loro
ma siccome è tutto da dimostrare io non
credo che ci riusciremmo che i giovani
adulti oggi non siano coloro ai quali
affidare l'agenda delle cose importanti
dicendo senti pensaci un po te
io credo che sia ora di cominciare a
intenderli per quello che sono davvero
cioè un vento in grado di
intervenire sui cambiamenti di stato del
mare
ma per fare questo dobbiamo ammettere
che implichi renderci conto di tutto
quello che noi abbiamo sbagliato fin qui
tutte le scelte sbagliate prese fin qui
la fragilità è all'origine della
comprensione del bisogno ha scritto
vittorino andreoli nel suo libro l'uomo
di vetro intendeva dire che è solo
quando siamo fragili e ci rendiamo è
davvero conto di che cosa ci occorre
ora su quanto la fragilità sia un tratto
strutturale dell'essere umano e su come
usando un po di pensiero laterale sia
fin troppo semplice farle una buona
pubblicità hanno già detto e scritto in
tanti e non è quello che voglio fare io
oggi con voi io voglio fare un'altra
cosa
voglio provare a raccontare questi
adulti giovani per come mi sembra che
siano davvero perché sono in gamba in
gambissima sono smart sono contemporanei
sono figli del loro tempo si interrogano
sul senso si interrogano sul futuro si
interrogano sulle soluzioni
si appellano alla logica del gusto e
luogo di quella del profitto
ma sanno anche che fragilità non vuol
dire nulla
se non che non si possa essere in nessun
altro modo
e questo a noi che siamo più vecchi
mette a disagio
il loro disagio ci imbarazza perché ci
sbatte sotto al naso che lo siamo da
sempre anche noi
fragili
ci stanno sbattendo sotto al naso che si
possa vivere in un altro modo che non è
il nostro
si può non dire di sì a tutto si può non
farsi andare bene qualunque cosa si può
studiare qualcosa solo perché ti
interessa anche se poi non ti darà un
lavoro sicuro
si può cambiare idea
si può aspettare
si può non dover dire grazie per delle
condizioni minime se non a volte
miserevoli si può non voler subire il
nonnismo della gavetta
si può
sono un vento che spezza ma che non
viene spezzato anche se le stiamo
trattando come dei sudditi acquistiamo
precludendo l'occasione di diventare un
giorno sovrani
persone mia norberto bobbio
o ambra alla fine si è licenziata quando
ha rassegnato le dimissioni
mi ha raccontato che il suo capo era
convinto che lei mollasse perché aveva
trovato qualcosa di meglio
un lavoro più pagato più vicino a casa
mi ha detto che sia lui che i suoi
genitori quando invece lei ha spiegato
che no
lei lascia e basta perché non è quello
che vuole fare si è sentita dare
dell'incosciente di quella che non ha
capito quale grande fortuna fosse avere
un lavoro
lei non sa cosa farà adesso intanto se
finalmente messo a scrivere la tesi che
discute a dicembre
e poi mi ha detto che forse pensa a del
volontariato al servizio civile ma detto
o forse un corso di lingua all'estero
non lo sa
può non saperlo si vedrà
nel frattempo ma anche detto perché
venisse in seduta con il libro della
lugo sky a mi ha detto stai
io temevo di non avere mai niente di
nuovo da venirti a dire
avevo paura di non essere una delle
pazienti che ti avrebbe insegnato
qualcosa
e invece guarda
[Applauso]